[Applaus]
wie gewohnt dass die
[Musik]
das war knapp das war knapp oder wie man
ihm eine serbische heimat café im profi
gesagt das war knapp
wer weiß wann wir nächstes essen
gekommen
kommt auch alle zehn sekunden
deswegen gibt es keine fahrplan
herr schmeiß hirn
aber da wir nun mal glück gehabt weil
hätte ja sein können nächstes essen dann
werden vielleicht stadteigener zwei
schrauben drin gesessen habe ich schon
gesagt dass in der grundschulhalle ich
bin ich kann und das ist meine mutter
wie mutter deine mutter krebs nicht sie
sind die mutter ja ich bin die mutter
was haben sie denn gedacht habt ihr das
gemacht
[Applaus]
so und jetzt wollt ihr auch nach oben
sparen sie sich ein blödes gesetze
sitzen jetzt hier ein paar minuten
nebeneinander und dann sehen wir uns nie
wieder
und mein gott das bleibt da stehen keine
sorgen einmal bis dauert nun mal nicht
langsamer kind zeit ist relativ und am
längsten ist sie wenn man neben einem
volltrottel sitzt nicht ist aber auch
nicht so toll ich sitze neben alte
schachtel
das ist nichts persönliches die es immer
sehr viel vielleicht maxime ich nicht
weil die bin ausländer das hat mit
ausländer gar nichts zu tun idioten sind
internationen sagt nie wieder
international zu mir
ich verpassten total süßen akzent wir
gehen jetzt bitte ich bin schütze akzent
waage
was sich heutzutage auf diesen ski
pisten herumtreibt wirklich unglaublich
das hat es früher nicht gegeben
skifahren das war früher eine sportart
für menschen mit klasse mädchen die
klasse h boot so lacht
skifahren ist die blödeste sportart
überhaupt die ganzen skifahrer schauen
aus wie astronauten von einem sehr sehr
dumme plane ich war mit sessel auf berg
hinauf mit chemie darunter die wissen
damit dass man auch wieder mit dessen
hinterfragen
meine tochter und ich mir leben das
skifahren ja bestimmt sein wobei ich so
gern mal am nordhang vom holzvogel
fahren würde aber meine mutter die hat
immer angst vor den ganzen schwarzen
super alte schabracke markt keine yukos
mag eine schwarze sag mal gute frau bist
du siehst hätte versprechen von den
schwarzen pisten es gibt schwarze pisten
ich selber los weiß
wirklich überhaupt keine ahnung aber
sagt man wenn du gar nicht schief erst
was machst du denn hier geschäfte ich
bin geschäftsmann weißt du bund so
export import
was verkaufen sie da so waffen drogen
verkauft keine waffe serie ist kann ich
zeigen unsere neue kollektion
für die haltesignale
fahrbericht alle ich dich und dann habe
ich hier noch wunderschön habe ich auch
noch golden youth golden eu dies ganz
golden vor ihnen nur ausnahme besteht
und dann habe ich auch noch wunderbare
heißen tee heißt hat er jetzt toll die
halskette die sieht auch ganz hübsch
katharina siehst du nicht dass das alles
diebesgut ist das stimmt überhaupt nicht
die t habe ich selbst gekocht
ja also
wir hier noch länger rumhängen dann dann
nehme ich auch einen thw gleich gewusst
habe gleich gewusst
dass auch schön große del ferro
wehrte elf euro für zwei
euro für junge frau und zehn euro für
halten
das ist einfach eine unverschämtheit ja
ich nix machen die preise
du kannst gerne kaufen woanders kommt
gewährt
kaum gibt geld das recht nicht ganz
verstößt muss man machen korrekt immer
korrekt weiß und süß korrekt an tische
praktisch korrekt super so
massiv an marine die beste geschäft man
lernt nette leute kennen wie wär's mit
später vielleicht noch ein bisschen
après ski wissen sie was ich nehme das
mit dem vollidioten zurück denn sie sind
ein ober granaten vollidiot
xd ich habe gemeint ich habe gemeint die
nette frau sie glauben doch nicht dass
meine tochter mit ihnen ausgeht warum
eigentlich nicht katharina ich habe
keine lust jeden tag um sie morgens
schon auf der piste zu stehen vor allem
auf einer piste die nicht steiler ist
als unsere garagenauffahrt
dann kann ich auch lieber mal zu machen
okay ist ausgemacht mama brasilien laden
da gibt es die besten ist ibiza
dann muss nicht schnell schauen
wo kollege hat geschäft gemacht hervor
auf die riesen super ganz
wiedereinschalten
[Gelächter]
mit wenig rettig rap und niemand hat's
so dienst bloß gedacht
einschalten schnell einschalten haben
sie diesen lift her angehalten wie man
in gemeldete frau ganz genau was ich
meine raum unter strache sonst schneidig
sie augenblicklich herunter ja mein gott
dritten station sieht meinen freund
verstößt und erhält die man lief der
bislang mehr zeit um geschäfte zu machen
aber jetzt jetzt fährt er nicht weiter
weiß nicht was los ist vielleicht dies
auf klose was ich auch noch mal ich
schon mal los jetzt habe ich sofort
dieses gerät
das ist schlecht
jetzt wird besser länger dauern mit
après ski
können wir nicht jemanden anrufen kein
netz was machen wir denn jetzt hier zu
tode langweilen nichts muss zu tode
langweilen pass auf frau brauchst du
flacke fernsehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]